hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein einfaches rezept und
zwar mache ich so ein mediterranes brot
mit oliven mit peperoni und dazu gibt es
noch einen tipp dieser tipp gibt es also
diesen tipp gibt es bei uns ganz oft und
zwar eigentlich regelmäßig am wochenende
war mehr als ich dann immer zum
frühstück wünscht und ich will jetzt
einfach mal sagen ich zeig euch jetzt
erstmal die zutaten für den teig wir
stellen so als das brot her und später
dann eben für die für den käse tipp das
wird länger es wird richtig lecker aber
von richtig leckeres brot an zutaten
brauchen wir einen würfel hefe 300 gramm
warmes wasser drei esslöffel honig 500
gramm mehl 2 esslöffel salz 1 esslöffel
rosmarin 1 esslöffel oregano fünf
esslöffel olivenöl und hier habe ich
noch 100 gramm peperoni und 150 gramm
gemischte oliven so es nämlich jetzt die
hefe und geht die bereits in meiner
schüssel
da kommt was er mit dazu und auch drei
esslöffel honig
und das ist vom rezept her so ähnlich
wie mein parkett
aber ein bisschen anders jetzt ruhig das
gut durch damit sich die hefe auflösen
lässt
jetzt gebe ich noch das mehl mit dazu
die in ali carter hinten in ihrem
laufstall hat stress mit dem platz sagte
moratti
dann kommen noch zwei esslöffel salz und
auch gleich die gewürze mit rein also
auch groß marin und oregano ihr könnt
natürlich auch andere gewürze benutzen
also je nachdem was ihr da habt und was
er gerne mögen das ist jetzt auch der
rosmarin den ich getroffen und habe auf
der terrasse oder von der tat ab und zu
hause getrocknet und jetzt lasse ich es
kurz durchschütteln und gebt dann auch
gleich das olivenöl mit rein also fünf
esslöffel
in zeigt das jetzt etwa 45 minuten
kneten und in der zwischenzeit scheidet
schon mal paroli und die oliven klein
und bei den caroni ob das noch viel
wasser drin ist in dieser eigentlich
eingelegten und dann nehme ich dann auch
die kerne raus die möchte ich da nicht
mit drin haben
ein paar oliven habe ich jetzt
aufgehoben die gebe ich später obendrauf
der jetzt nicht klein geschnitten und
jetzt gebe ich die zutaten hier mit rein
und lassen sie auch kurz ein kneten
der text fertig und das ist so ein
richtig klebriger teig und jetzt habe
ich hier meine backformen 2 steht das
backblech dieser krusty baic form also
dass es eben schön knusprig packt aber
ich mache es nicht direkt darauf sondern
auch eine backpapier denn der klar der
teig da klebt auch ziemlich nämlich ein
bisschen olivenöl so etwa einen
esslöffel und streicht das backpapier
erstmal damit ein und gebe jetzt den
teig da drauf und es passt halt wirklich
alles gut zusammen also diese oliven mit
dem peperoni
ich hatte übrigens oliven die wahren
eingelegt und zwar in kräuter knoblauch
öl
die hatte ich an der frischetheke geholt
aber er könnte auch ganz normale
ungewünschte oliven benutzen gibt es
einen unterschied ob von bei der farbe
ja ich habe auch grüne und schwarze und
zwar ist es ja so die grünen diesen so
wissen fruchtiger und die schwarzen 10
eher herb und also ich hab das auch
immer gefragt und habe dann in der
türkei bei meinen onkels macht fragt
wenn sie haben seine oliven oliven
plantage wir haben nichts aus so also
wirklich richtig cool dort und die
grünen oliven das sind einfach die
unreife rinnen oliven und die schwarzen
sind eben länger am baumasse diese neben
gereifter aber da gibt es einen
unterschied beim kauf muss man darauf
achten dass man auf der verpackung guckt
und zwar gibt es auch oliven die werden
industriell eingefärbt und das ist dann
eben nicht so gut also man sollte schon
die nehmen die eben von natur aus
schwarz werden und in der türkei meine
cousine und die können alle dieses die
oliven so richtig toll einlegen das mit
so gut wirklich klasse ich finde ich sie
jetzt die peperoni ich sehe die oliven
drehen
die kreutherin uns gerade noch ein
bisschen öl in meiner hand und streicht
das was das will ich jetzt noch tollen
der was doch rein machen könntest ja ich
alles schon das wäre super wenn ich ein
paar stück hier rein
ja es wird super toll passen aber ich
möchte das brot vegetarisch halten
du kannst dazu essen außerdem kommt ja
auch dieser käse direkt mit dazu
die restlichen oliver die städte ich
einfach so gut drauf also in casey
weglassen mindestwert sogar veganer das
arbeiten also das brot an sich locker
weg
ich glaube ich keine tierischen zu tun
keine milch gar nichts nur wasser
honig hab ich drin ja murat ist da sind
wir beim thema honig ist nicht vegan
deswegen ist doch nicht vegan aber wenn
man dann stattdessen zucker nimmt
weswegen jetzt streicht noch ein
bisschen oregano darüber sieht dann auch
richtig toll aus und der ofen ist jetzt
übrigens noch aus also verschieben das
gleich in den kalten backofen und lassen
dann den teig einfach drin aufklären
jetzt sehe ich das mit sally ich glaube
die iller turbo gemacht und jetzt zeige
ich euch mal in einem backofen habe ich
nämlich was vorbereitet
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier das bak
rost worauf ich das jetzt gleich backen
werde heiße nicht der bacchus der
schlussgesang direkt und jetzt habe ich
hier noch 1 und hab dann eine glasschale
also eine offen fest der glasschale mit
einem liter wasser drin und es sorgt
dann gleich dafür dass wir eine richtig
tolle brüste haben
es kommt jetzt zu sein
und jetzt schalte ich erst im backofen
ein und zwar auf umluft 102 110 grad und
bugs dann da drin für etwa 35 bis 45
minuten wir schauen einfach gleich noch
mal rein
das brot gebacken und ich werde es noch
ganz heiß mit etwas wasser bestreichen
dann gehen nämlich auch schön machen das
nur wegen dem glanz und ich habe vorhin
das wasser im backofen gehabt damit das
brot eine richtig tolle kruste bekommt
man kann es auch besprühen aber ich habe
nicht so sprühen ganze wohnung liegt
übrigens noch richtig gut so und das
brot ist jetzt noch ein bisschen zu heiß
deswegen lass ich das kurz abkühlen und
kann in der zwischenzeit schon mal den
käfig zu bereiten und zwar brauchen wir
für den käse tipp hier habe ich käse und
reise so ein türkischer weichkäse br
spanish also aus kuhmilch um das sind
etwa 40 etwa 250 gramm
hier habe ich 200 gramm schlag sahne und
etwas näher das geht jetzt auch ganz
einfach ich gebe den käse in einem
kleinen topf und zerbröselt den so ein
bisschen mit den händen
und zwar haben wir darin käse der hat
ganz viel also einen hohen fettanteil er
ist auch ein ganz weiter käse ich hab da
hat sogar 60 prozent verdammt so dann
gebe ich da jetzt die sahne mit dazu und
stelle jetzt erstmal den herd ein damit
der käse schmelzen kann
jetzt kocht die mischung und jetzt gebe
ich ein esslöffel mehl mit rein damit es
eben auch dicker wird denn jetzt ist er
ganz flüssig jetzt müsste einfach schon
je nachdem was für einen käfer ihr habt
also es muss halt dickflüssig sein es
darf aber nicht zu dick sein
deswegen gebe ich immer erst mal einen
esslöffel mit rein mit sehe ich brauche
noch ein bisschen
also gebe ich noch mal so einen halben
mit rein gleichzeitig sollen rechtsstaat
genau das ist übrigens ein rezept habe
ich von meiner freundin und zwar machen
wir das ganze auch zum frühstück ist
wirklich sein ihres lieblings käse und
dann ist sie total gerne aufs brot aber
als tipp eignet es sich auch
hervorragend und mit schmeckt wirklich
richtig gut
und sobald ihr die gewünschte konsistenz
erreicht habt könnt ihr den herd
ausschalten dann ist der weg fertig und
man kenne noch aufhören also wenn ihr
mal etwas mehr habt müsst das danach
einfach wieder ein bisschen wahr machen
wir da wieder flüssig so ist es perfekt
fast pudding mäßig es freilich nicht
mehr als drei tage aufbewahren hebt das
sowieso nation im spiel zu lecker so
jetzt richtig dass an also man könnte es
jetzt natürlich auch schneiden aber ich
finde es irgendwie schöner wenn man es
einfach reist also man kann es auch
einfach am tisch machen
man sagt auch brot schneidet man man
reißt es von innen aus richtig lecker
aus jetzt gebe ich dir das mit dem tipp
und brate ich ja verspätete wollen ohne
wir ziehen jetzt zusammen macht ihr noch
ein kleines stück weil der htl auf genau
die villa und der tipp des einfach
genial dass reiner calmund probieren
relativ gut und richtig würzig geld also
hier in der wohnung nicht wirklich
richtig gut nach diesen oliven nach den
pepperoni also auch den ganzen gewürzen
und man könnte jetzt natürlich auch noch
olivenöl dazu reichen dass essen wie in
der türkei zum beispiel auch so da tut
man olivenöl brot in olivenöl aus muss
er darauf ein richtig qualitative so
leben als ein also ja man könnte steht
gibt es dazu und ich will es so schön
der käse wenn das rezept nach machen
wollt oder besser gesagt die rezepte
geht einfach auf meinem blog auf sex -
blog.de das steht noch mal alles ganz
genau und ihr könnt natürlich ihm brot
statt den oliven auch getrocknete
tomaten benutzen oder auch andere sachen
alles was euch einfällt der käse tipp
ist wirklich genial probiert ihn auf
jeden fall mein baum stück auf jeden
fall war genau war müsste in essen auf
jeden fall also sobald er kalt wird wird
er halt etwas fester deswegen immer
schön warm probieren und ja wenn es
schmeckt freut mich dass und ihr könnt
mir gerne ein feedback da lassen und wir
sehen uns dann wieder beim nächsten mal
ist wirklich genial da muss man 2 vor
allem ist genial einfach mal als
vorspeise oder auch mal als beilage oder
einfach mal so zwischendurch als snack
als ich find's toll auch zum frühstück
abendessen toll
die kräuter wahnsinn beginnt es auch so
passte mehr zu essen bisschen in
typischer schinken dazu in den ring
schicken models youtube also war max
macht bisschen länger machen was
erzählen
dann gehe ich